[Music]
Nathan's called the nation's report card
because these test scores consistently
measure student learning over time 20
19's results were just released and
warrant three takeaways and a caution
first results were grim math scores were
up a tick and fourth grade but they
dropped in eighth grade and both grades
dropped in reading indeed eighth grade
reading scores changed more than at any
time in that test history and in the
wrong direction second these declines
look worse against the backdrop of the
past decade while nape scores mostly
climbed from 1990 through 2010
performance stagnated cents and 2015 saw
widespread declines for the first time
until now
third declines were driven by our lowest
scoring students and since high
performing students stayed flat the gap
between them is growing a caution after
this lousy report card expect to see a
number of articles offering ped
explanations for the poor showing truth
is there are simply too many factors
involved to know exactly why scores
decline but even if they can't pinpoint
a cause these results are a sobering
reminder of where our students are are
you more concerned with the declines on
nape or on the growing divide between
low and high performing students let us
know in our poll also let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI